[Musik]
befindet
hallo unseres als heilig ist wieder ein
nachgemacht original trifft fell
heute mache ich ein amerikanisch konzept
mit deutschen wurzeln denn er kennt
vielleicht alle diese sneijder sind
diese kleinen dresden snacks sowie her
das heißt wie brezel die deutsche
grundlage und dann umgewandelt als prinz
max und jetzt auch nachgemacht im
geschmack halberstadt und anja also
honig senf und triebe und so sehen wir
bei mir auf ich hab sie einfach mit
frisch gebackenen brezeln gemacht die
waren jetzt zum bäcker für das selber
gebacken finde ich muss man auch gar
nicht denn das ist auch eine art
resteverwertung das heißt falls jemand
beratungen übrig habt könnt ihr einfach
diese flex drauf machen und wir sind
wirklich super zu verkaufen haben
und die sind für alle diese sonder die
originale sind wissing kleiner ok
probiere alles original ella maria das
ist aber gar nicht schlimm
die original so ein bisschen kleiner ich
habe etwas kürzer gelassen für mich
haben einfach map ist und vor allem die
hat einfach ein bisschen praktischer und
handlicher okay lass mich aber ich finde
unsere variante wirklich sehr lecker vor
allem ohne geschmacksverstärker und ohne
künstliche stoffe wirklich nur aus
natürlichen zutaten wenn auch nicht
länger für eine eineinhalbjährige aber
das wird gar nicht schlimm ich zeige
euch jetzt mal die zutaten und dann
legen wir gleich los ich habe ich bleib
rettung dann für die soße habe ich mir
50 gramm butter 100 g
ich habe ich gehört zu jeweils einem
viertel paprikapulver kurkuma pfeffer
und salz 50 komponist 30
richter john weißweinessig und eine
charlotte du es ist die soße hergestellt
dafür gäbe jetzt alle zutaten in einen
topf den ich setze einfach vorher kurz
aufkochen und verbindet sich alles schön
die aromen entfalten sind
[Musik]
und vor allem ist dann auch die
feuchtigkeit ein bisschen weniger wind
ein kocht und die presse sie trocknen
schneller in baku
danach der horror
und fertig und für den säbel geschmack
nehme ich jetzt ne charlotte also in den
original produkte natürlich nur pulver
machen
die pulver honig puls einfach aber wir
nehmen jetzt die ganz natürlichen
zutaten und kochen das ganze und dann
geht eben die feuchtigkeit wächst und so
klappte es auch ganz gut dass bibel wird
es fein gerieben
und hier entscheidet sie einfach selbst
wie viele nächte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und die zusagen beiden jetzt berühren
dann lasse ich sie aufkochen und werden
das hier auftaucht kann es hier auf der
seite schon mal zu nehmen und das ist
auch so eine richtig tolle
resteverwertung das heißt wenn alte
brezeln hab einfach so weiter verweisen
und rettungsweg draus machen
die mischung hier lasse ich jetzt
übrigens etwa ein bis zwei minuten lang
köcheln jetzt einfach samt ungleichmäßig
in stücke schneiden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt habe ich die brezeln hier auf eine
backpfeife gegeben auf mein bett lag und
da kommt jetzt die soße drüber
[Musik]
und standorte
ich glaube ich den fast noch eine brezel
oder so
danke sagen also für die augen ist das
gar nicht denn die säure vom esstisch
die zwiebeln steigt alles in die augen
und da muss man meinen
[Musik]
ich muss sagen für sehen aus wie die
original und vor allem riefen sie auch
schon schmecken tun sie schon besser sie
kommen jetzt so in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 150 grad heißluft also ist
es auch hier mit heißluft damit sie eben
schon trockenen schön groß werden und da
werde ich jetzt etwas 30-60 mit unseren
lassen
zwischendurch muss auch immer mal wieder
um die briefwechsel ist fertig ich hatte
für 30 minuten bei 150 grad heiß und
dann habe ich die hitze herunter grill
auf 100 grad damit sie einfach nicht
frauen werden sondern einfach so schön
goldgelb bleiben
habt ihr dann noch mal für 30 minuten
weiter getrocknet und dann den ofen
ausgestellt und mit offener tür die
ganzen mit brezeln zunächst einfach auf
hatten und auskühlen lassen so faste ich
mich vor schluss aber habe ich nicht und
hier sind jetzt die fettige snacks sind
jetzt auch schon abgekühlt und die
werden auch durch abkühlen schön kross
also jetzt zum vergleich jedoch
originale hier das original
und ich muss sagen also geschmacklich
nicht schmackhaft fahren also oft finde
ich meine filme ich finde ich einfach
appetitlicher auf und wieso so künstlich
gelb aussehen geschmack ich finde ich
beide gut weil sie kennt man halt und
wenn man original produkt kennt findet
schmeckt irgendwie immer gut mit
kindheitserinnerungen und meist einfach
auch gewohnt aber ich muss sagen
geschmacklich gefällt gefallen mit die
auf jeden fall viel besser hier einmal
original svanstedt und muss sagen sie
sind ein bisschen deutlicher fällig
warnstreik warten noch unklar
auch bei coach labbadia
[Musik]
11.40 uhr an hat noch nicht probiert und
ella gibt keinem einem punktgewinn beide
fußball und schreiben ist aber falls ihr
die auch mal nachmachen wollt dann geht
es endlich los und verließ - blog.de
dass sie das rezept noch mal ganz genau
falls ihr den geschmack intensiver haben
mit mir ist einfach eine brezel weniger
also die ganze menge für nur 3 betteln
wenn ihr sagt ein bisschen milder ist es
oder nimmt auch für brezeln sind beide
varianten ganz gut und vielleicht
probiert irgendwann noch mal eine ganz
andere geschmacks kombination aus
vielleicht entwickle ich selber mal eine
geschmacksrichtung und falls ihr euch
das wünscht mir einfach und ich mach zu
sagen ganz gerne
also viel spaß und nachmachen und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]